what's up guys we're pong fancy we're
back with another episode of challenge
for infinity don't forget leave your
comments and ideas in the comment
section bellow you would kind of like
need a pillow or something for it
ah much better you know you look
comfortable
[Music]
[Applause]
no fair
like Oh actually what actually works
[Music]
[Applause]
good have to do it one standing yeah I
exactly up
[Music]
oh well three that was good
and there's 79% of you guys who haven't
subscribed back channels to remember to
do it right now
[Music]
oh hey Mike I think we should both lay
down that sounds a bit this course that
was perfect whoo
[Music]
[Applause]
now we're gonna play one manís doubles
match so every other shutting with the
right time
a rather should with the left hand let's
go come on
shoot back in to one please going pretty
well for one ah good serve ah come on
[Music]
come on
or fixes
oh that's just a pretty-pretty thumb
table
[Music]
I try to difficult shots we live with
the letter
[Music]
yeah whoo that was a big point that was
a Bigfoot
good point so this is difficult
Oh inside
thank you good fun okay now let's make
the world's biggest Table Tennis spats
and let's start off with three layers
well there is some thickness already
it's very easy to hit the edge with the
backhand is really good with the curtain
[Music]
Oh edgy time for some more layers yep
that's four layers so eight rubbers
I don't think ITTF would approve this
racket in a tournament it's so fast it's
like playing with a trampoline or
something boy boy
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
oh I think it's time to add on some more
layers we need to make it thicker so the
next one is going to be ten rubbers so
five layers I think we're gonna need
some heavy-duty edge tape all right well
there's ten okay let's put some
videotape since it's art in this yeah
well this is a beta 11 three of you
three one yeah I think chopping is test
yeah
oh I think the best way might be to
actually just play with the edge
it's so big the edge to that it's quite
easy to play with it look at that smash
which one shall we take nice is a good
one
Roger sir laying on you have some more
[Music]
six six layers well this is heavy it's
so heavy
it's so big movement like handle woman
yeah but so slow shots this is really
slowing you down with the racket no oh
[Music]
second you can still actually play
pretty well with it it's time for more
layers
all right so 12 times 12 that's already
looking for I think wow this looks
really
[Music]
the sound is so weird I think it's time
for me to step in
let's try to go for ten on each side so
we have it ten layers it's pretty thick
[Applause]
how does it feel okay it's quite slow
but you can play with it
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let's let's let's add as many as we
still have yeah lets us put everything
that we have on it
[Music]
16 layers it's 32 rubbers I think this
is the world's biggest tables in
Australia 1finity special no it doesn't
look like it's right it's gotten even
slower but really this were slow that's
a really good loop yeah thanks those
penis and part it's heavy
[Applause]
oh so heavy
come on hard
[Applause]
[Music]
ah yes good spill okay so a normal table
since racket weighs around hundred and
seventy grams and we calculated that
this is approximately one half kilos so
that's about three pounds it is quite
heavy okay so let's try five our on two
nuts with the edge of the racket
[Applause]
[Music]
okay this was a bit difficult even for
me but I know what to use now it must be
possible
[Music]
[Music]
Wow
thanks for watching guys remnants here
subscribe and check out previous videos
there until next time